non ça c'est quoi c'est vrai quoi
meslois vraiment non mais c'est vrai il
paraît que c'est vrai je les ai jamais
cachées je les classe et je les cas fiez
vous adresser ce sont les invités qui
vont jouer donc d'accord je vous montre
des phobies et vous allez me dire à qui
elle appartient attention c'est parti
mettez la liste des phobies merci c'est
tout alors voilà il ya une personne
autour de la table qui a peur des
manèges
à votre avis qui a peur des manèges à la
même deux il y en a deux qui ont pions
ddd marie-mai ses marines et luan à
votre avis qui a peur des manèges autour
de la table sont dans la lys les filles
l'ont elles sont dans la liste
officielle ou non mais oh sees les deux
filles soient pas d'accord alors
marinello appris à faire des manèges
penser que c'est qu'il y autour de la
table il y en a 12 c'est de ces deux
mecs je vous le dis vous dit
alors alors des manèges autour de la
table allez jeter un voile ou baba sy et
vous marine
vous pensez que c'est qu'ils auraient
bien dit laouni la holy qui a peur des
malaises mahfal déjà laouni déballage ou
mangez pas peur des mots c'est fini ben
c'est thierry beau et julien courbet
faisait peur des manèges
depuis un saut en élastique au dessus de
bordeaux pour une émission pour france
rouges avaient accepté de faire ça la
grue était à 60 mètres et depuis j'ai le
vertige et dès que ça tourne etc mais je
deviens fou c'est vrai c'est pas
bordeaux ça c'est à bordeaux est très
bon on a les images non et si regardez
on a le saut à l'élastique de julien
courbet regard de fou c'est vrai
regardez il ya 25 ans en direct ici sur
le port de bordeaux
je pensais que j'étais un homme super
courageux et bien je suis bien déçu de
voir que j'ai une sacrée trouille à cinq
mètres du sol je vais faire un saut pour
faire plaisir à mon producteur adoré
pour lui montrer que je suis pas une
mauviette
alors peut-être à jamais peut-être à
tout à l'heure pour une après-midi en
tout cas très enflammée on est préservé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
aujourd'hui continuer et que j'ai pas pu
faire mais par une allusion
impossible selon j'ai adopté cette cloud
cavale et a demandé qu'un manège qui
tourne ou des quais de la hauteur mais
j'ai la trouille et même harcèlement
quand même un petit train fantôme quand
même tu te rends compte au bout on va
sommer en sorte d'en battre et dia qui à
notre avis a la phobie des clowns blancs
la phobie des clowns blancs autour de la
table et pourquoi blanc balas cahill et
de voilà il ya des couleurs
oui il y avait jean michel qui aimait
pas les canaris ont mis autour de la
table alors à votre avis l'udc jean luc
coudray
jean luc lemoine ce que vous avez peur
des coups de blanc rouge et bien voilà
c'est ces vigiles
ah oui à quoi sert vous avez vraiment
peur des coûts nous terrifier voix
c'est-à-dire dès que vous voyez au congo
ah ben je peux pas quoi j'ai je pense
qu'il va me poignarder qui va me mettre
anglais qui gère le maquillage blanc
d'un cloud ça me terrifie les crs à
supporter ça ah ouais ça tout va faire
de toi aussi je vous fait quoi combien
coûte blot jeu je m'attendais je les
laisse les évitons les jamais vu en
crise et depuis j'en ai vu à la télé mes
parents m'avaient abandonné j'ai cassé
la vitre pour philo je pense que je suis
le peuple avide de la télé tu as fait
quoi la vie de la maison j'ai fui je me
suis j'ai failli mourir parce que je me
suis mis les les
les poignets dans la vie tellement
j'avais peur ah ouais quand même var est
donc ça va ça va est-ce que je peux
quitter l'émission
[Applaudissements]
qui a peur des serpents
autour de la table qui a peur des
serpents y en a un ou une qui a très
très peur des serpents il a vraiment la
phobie des serpents marine non à ces
infos beat fille quand même thème
non vous vous avez peur quelque chose
hein c'est ça j'ai peur de choses moi
dit rien non plus passé et n'aura qu'à
peur des serpents
non c'est pas une aura c'est là au nid
c'est la fouine table à dessin j'avais
vraiment peur des serpents
non mais en tant que rappeur je n'ai
peur de rien vrai il fallait voir là
donc j'ai un peu peur des vosges et pas
peur des soeurs malheureusement on n'a
pas peur de serpents jeudi parce qu'on
n'a pas le droit d'envoyer sur le
plateau n'a pas droit mais on en a eu
sur les premières fois sourire gentier
toute épreuve
c'est mon nouvel ascenseur pense qu'un
intermittent du spectacle aux bretons
dans toutes les émissions
c'est vrai
car je dois de loi de m me mettez nous
embrasse le sujet il fait pas peur en
fait si peur de rien il a touché à l'est
s'il vous plaît j'ai peur de mal à me
séparer
julien c'est bon il me dit moi dessus tu
fais exprès non j'aimerais j'ai vraiment
pas par moi j'adore les serpents elle
est sortie deux ans avec un serpent 3 à
3 3
j'ai une peur de mettre la tête sous
l'eau qui a peur de mettre la tête sous
l'eau et qui a peur de mettre la tête
sous l'eau et à l'environnement isabel
explique surprise c'est pour ça que j'ai
aura laissé pour nous
a longtemps dit qui a peur de mettre la
tête sous l'eau vraiment c'est sa phobie
des tests neuro isabelle ac n'aura c'est
une horreur c'est vrai qu'ici j'ai fait
du surf quand j'étais petit j'ai failli
me noyer et depuis
vraiment c'est impossible pour moi quand
je nage de mettre la tête sous l'eau
j'ai l'impression que j'ai crevé c'est
impossible je vais y ont paniqué thierry
aussi pareil parce que quand j'étais
gamin j'ai commencé à apprendre à nager
quand j'étais au bord de la mer et en
rentrer une fois chez moi ma mère a
voulu continuer à me faire prendre des
cours j'étais dans une piscine je
marchais au bord de la piscine
le mec maître nageur était un militaire
il a dit ben on va voir ce qu'il sait
faire il m'a poussé non c'est pas une
loyer le militaire est là ce soir et moi
c'est pareil j'ai peur de l'eau parce
que mon père a cédé me noyer quand
j'étais petit alors qui qu'ils aient les
mygales qui est les mygales une personne
ici qui est les montagnes ses marines et
marina marine faisait détester les
mygales vraiment vous détestez les
mygales je déteste déjà leur sérieux
collège fait passer la main moite et
tout ça et il a regardé derrière alors
ça ça va c'est juste un petit médecin
c'était pas ça c'est pas palais dans la
boîte ouais mais bon rien lâché non non
je le fais moi c'est vrai ouais
vas-y d'accord bbq
non
elle est super gentil j'adore les
mygales j'adore ça allait super aqua
c'est bon à ses dires il a vu que vous
faites quoi vous fêter ça avec tout
allait trop mignon mais c'était trop
bien je vous dis moi j'adore les mygales
j'adore j'adore la lafam d'ailleurs la
mygale et la fourmi mais vous faites le
test avec tous ceux qui ont peur en fait
je vais changer ma peur j'ai vraiment
super peur quand une femme nue via me
lécher le ventre luan elle n'a pas peur
des mygales
elle a pas peur des serpents elle a une
phobie à la peur des bananes c'est vrai
que vous avez peur des ballades mais un
truc de fou j'adore ça ou alors vous
savez que moi moi malheureusement j'ai
toujours une banane chambre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non non non mais qu'est ce qui se passe
si vous voyez une balade a eu très peur
des bananes il sait où cette phobie des
bananes ça s'appelle ça s'appelle la
banane ou la banane aux femmes la banane
of avis la banane aux phobies mais on a
eu un traumatisme je sais pas je sais
pas à mettre quoi c'est vrai ça va aller
vite et vous voyez une banane neurones
ça c'est pire que c'est pire que tout le
monde ici sait quand tu coûtes banana
split de lio pareil tu veux pas c'est
quoi c'est vrai quoi meslois vraiment
non mais c'est vrai il paraît que c'est
vrai je laissais aller je les cache et
j'ai cassé je lé quartier doit son nom
elle veut pas voir ça ça y est gelé car
les lois du jeu les cacher c'est bon il
a beau bilan mais sur une de mes tongs
jusqu'à tôt quand vous passez devant le
haut devant devant des bananes au marché
vous imaginez lwen au marché selon elle
pas s'il ya des potes et bada non mais
ça m'a inscrit pas je pleure pas tout va
bien mais c est quand vous envoyez à la
télé même des bananes vous avez vu un
film d'horreur avec des bananes des
rebelles comme il y avait la tacc de la
banane géante crois que ça a tué non
mais c'est quoi voilà chacun ses phobies
c'est une phobie un peu bizarre c'est
vrai mais bon
mais vraiment vous pouvez pas la
regarder la banane sérieusement
c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon
d'accueillir bernois
[Applaudissements]
allez c'est bon allez c'est bon on
accueille d'après on accueille des
reproches à nauroy on n'a qu'à bientôt
ça va
[Musique]